,
In this demo I will solve a set of examples to find
Equations of lines in the form of the intersection of inclination
With a little revision, this means line equations
Y = mx + b where m is the inclination
And b is the intersection of y
Let us solve a set of these issues. So here
We gave that line a mi-5, that's m
= -5
The y intersection is 6
Ie b = 6
It's direct
The equation of this line is y =
5x + 6-
It was not bad
Let us move on to the following equation
The line inclination is -1 and contains
Point 4 / 5.0
We gave that inclination, the tilt is -1
If we know that m = -1, we would not
100% sure about the location of the y intersection
We know that this equation will take the form of y
= Tilt 1x + b, where b is
Intersection y
Now, we can use this coordinate information
Where they contain this point, we can use those
Information to find b
Since the font contains this point it means that
The x value is equal to 4/5, and y = 0 must be achieved
This equation
Let us compensate them in the equation, y = 0 when x
= 4/5
If 0 = -1 × 4/5 + b
I will go down a little
Let's see, we get 0 = -4.5 + b
We can add 4/5 to both ends of the equation
We can add 4/5 here
We can add 4/5 to this aspect as well
This is why I have done so until we delete this
We get b = 4/5
b = 4/5
Now we have the line equation
y = -1 × x, where you can write -x
+ b, ie 4/5, so
Now we have these
The line contains point 2.6 and 5.0
We were not given the inclination or the intersection of y
clearly
But we can find them out of this
Coordinates
The first thing we can do is find a tilt
We know that the slope m = change in y /
The change in x, and equal - what is the change in y?
Let's start this now
6 - 0
Let me do it that way
If this is 6 - you want to color it
6 - 0, this is the change in y
The change in x is 2 - 2 -5
The reason I am his color is that I want to see you
When I use the phrase y this first, I have used 6 here, where
Use this x phrase first as well
I want to show you that this coordinates 2.6
This coordinates is 5.0
I can not replace 2 and 5 after that
Then I get the negative image of the answer
But what did we get here?
This equals 6 - 0 = 6
2 - 5 = -3
If it becomes 6/3, the equivalent
If this is the inclination
We know that the line must be, y =
Tilt - Write this in orange - -2x x
+ Intersection y
Now we can do exactly what we did in the last question
We can use one of these tee points we find b
We can use any one
They are all on the line, if they all have to be achieved
This equation
I will use 5.0 because it is always good when
We have 0
The calculation is a bit simpler
So let's put 5.0 here
y = 0 when x = 5
If y = 0 when we have -2 × 5, when
x = 5 + b
We get 0 = -10 + b
If we add 10 to the sides of the equation, let's add 10
For both parties, delete these
We get b = 10 + 0, ie 10
If we get b = 10
Now we know the line equation
The equation is y - let me write it in another color - y =
-2x + b + 10
We're done
Let's solve one another
Well, the line contains 3.5 points and
3.0-
As in another issue, we begin to find
Inclination, or as we call m
It is equivalent to height / dimension, ie
Equivalent to change in y / change in x
If you want to apply this to your homework, do not
You have to write all this
I want to make sure that you understand this
All are equal
Then what is the change in y / change in x?
That's worth it, let's start this side first
So I'll show you that I can pick any of these points
Let's say it's 0-5 like this
I use this coordinate first. I will consider it
Completion point
Remember that when I learned this for the first time, I always wanted to
Place the x in the numerator
No, put y in the rugs
This is the second of the coordinates
Will be / -3-3
- 3
This coordinates 3,0-
This coordinates 3.5
We ask that
What will we get?
That's worth - I'll write
Another color - this is worth, in our rugs
-5 / -3 - 3 = -6
If the negative signal is deleted
And we get 5/6
We know that the equation will be y
= 5 / 6x + b
Now we can make up for one of these coordinates
Let's do it
Always use the best coordinate that contains 0
If y = 0 when x = -3 + b
All I did was I compensated -3 place x, 0 place y
I know I can do it because it is on line
This must achieve the line equation
Let us find b
If we get 0 =, if we divide 3
3 3, the result is 1
If we divide 6 3 3 it equals 2
Becomes 5/2 + b
We can add 5/2 to both ends of the equation
+ 5/2, + 5/2
I like to change the icon up
You are familiar with both pictures
If equation 5/2 = - this is 0--
= b
b = 5/2
If the line equation is y = 5 / 6x + b
As we have created 5/2, if + 5/2
We're done
Let's solve one another
We have a chart here
Let us find the equation of this graph
In fact it is, to some extent, a little easier
What is the tendency?
The slope is the change in y / change in x
Let's see what happens
When we move on x, when the change in x is 1, if this is
Change in x
The change in x is 1
I decided to change the x by 1
What is the change in y?
It seems that y is changing by 4
It seems that delta y, or change in y = 4
When delta is x = 1
If the change in y / change in x, the change in y is 4 when
The change in x = 1
If tilt = 4
And the intersection of y?
Well, here we can look at the chart
It appears to intersect with y axis on y =
-6, or on point 0, -6
We know that b = -6
b = -6
If we know the equation of the line
The equation of this line is y = x x
+ Intersection y
I have to write this
- 6, this + -6. If these are
Line equation
Let's solve one another
We gave that f (1.5) = -3, and
f (-1) = 2
What is that?
Well, this is a way of telling you that
Point when x = 1.5 in pairing
The pairing evaluates by -3
This shows that the coordinates 1.5, -3 are located
On-line
Then tell us that when x = -1, the
f (x) = 2
It's an excellent way to illustrate both
The two dots are on the line, there is nothing strange
I think the idea of ​​this matter is to become
The pairing code is familiar to you, so do not worry if
I saw something like that
If you set the pairing to 1.5, you get -3
If this is a coordinate if you imagine that y
= (f (x
This will be the y coordinate
And equals -3 when x = 1.5
Anyway, I've said this several times
Let us find the inclination of this line
The slope is the change in y / change in x =
Let 's start with 2 - this, ie - 3 - these are
Values ​​y-- /, all this
1. This
Let's write this way, -1 -
This, ie 1.5
I use colors because I want to show you that
-1 and 2 both came from this, and that's why I used it
Each of them first, if I use these first, will be on me
Use both x and y oa. If you use 2 first
I would have to use the first one. That's why you
Coloring
It becomes our 2 - 3
This is equivalent to 2 + 3
IE5
1 - or
-1 - 1.5 = -2.5
2.5
5 2.5 2.5 = 2
If the slope of this line is -2
In fact I'll take it aside until you make it clear that it is not
It matters what arrangement I put
If you use this coordinate first, then I should use it
First coordinate. Let us do it another way
If you put a 3 - 2 / 1.5 -
-1, this should be 2 / 1.5- -
-1
- 1
It should give me the same answer
How much is this?
-3 - 2 = -5, / 1.5 - -1
This is equivalent to 1.5 + 1
/ 2.5
Again, this equals -2
I just wanted to show you that it does not matter which one
We choose as a beginning or end point, as long as
Fixed
If this is the beginning, this is the x-chord
If this is the end, this is x
x End
But anyway, we know that the tilt is -2
If we know that the equation is y = -2x
+ Intersection y
Let us use one of these coordinates
I will use this since it does not contain a decimal point
We know that y = 2
If y = 2 when x = -1
When x = -1
Of course we have a positive b
If 2 = -2 × -1 = 2 + b
If we subtract 2 from both ends of the equation
-2, -2, from both ends
Equation, we get 0 on the left side
= b
If b = 0
If the line equation is y
= -2x
y = -2x
In fact if you want to write it in a coupling
It will be f (x) = -2x
I have assumed that y = f (x
But this equation
Y is not mentioned here
If you can write f (x) = 2x here
Each of these coordinates is coordinates
For x and f (x)
You may also consider defining the tilt as change
In the (f) x / change in x
These are all ways to review the same thing
.